en un juego de cartas se usan 36 cartas
distintas agrupadas en cuatro para los
diamantes corazones tréboles y espadas
cada uno con cartas numeradas del 1 al 9
así que cada palo tiene nueve cartas 9 x
4 nos dan las 36 cartas distintas una
mano está formada por nueve cartas
independientemente de su orden
repartidas aleatoriamente esto qué
quiere decir pues simplemente que una
mano te reparten nueve cartas tú no
sabes que te toca y no importa cómo las
acomode es cuál es la probabilidad de
que los 41 salgan en una mano así que
bien nos piden encontrar la probabilidad
de que todos los unos todos los unos
estén
en una mano
de 9 cartas en una mano de 9 y bien esto
quizás se vea como algo difícil de
entender porque o al menos de calcular
porque son demasiadas las combinaciones
que nos podrían tocar de las cartas pero
recordemos que la definición de
probabilidad nunca cambia la
probabilidad siempre va a ser el número
número de eventos favorables eventos
favorables
favorables y qué quiere decir eso pues
son los eventos que satisfacen mi
condición en este caso un evento
favorable es una mano en la que estén
todos los cuatro unos ya eso lo voy a
dividir entre
el número total de eventos número total
total de eventos
en este caso un evento simplemente es
una mano en el juego sea o no que
contenga todos los unos así que bien
vamos a calcular primero esto el número
total de eventos como les decía el
número total de eventos es el número
total
de manos posibles
de manos
posibles
posibles y bien cuánto es esto pues la
primera carta que me den tiene que ser
una de las 36 cartas distintas que hay
así que la primera es puede ser
cualquiera de 36 la segunda pues ya me
dieron una así que puede ser una de 35
para la tercera carta ya use dos cartas
así que puede ser una en 34 y así
sucesivamente hasta que obtenga mis
nueve cartas 33 32 31 30 29
y 28 sin más no esto ya son 9 123456789
bien
pero si sólo considero este número estoy
repitiendo eventos porque da lo mismo si
me dan el digamos 3 de tréboles primero
o si me lo dan en mi cuarta carta así
que tengo que dividir entre el número de
formas en las que puedo reacomodar mi
mano de 9 cartas la primera carta el
primer lugar puedo poner 9 cartas en el
en el segundo lugar puedo poner ahora
solo 8 en el tercero 7 y así hasta
agotar mis 9 lugares disponibles por 5
por 4 por 3 por 2 por 1
ahora bien para los que ya sepan un poco
de combinatoria
esto lo podrán identificar como el
coeficiente binomial
de 36 en 9 también otro modo de decir
esto es las combinaciones de 36 objetos
tomando 9 a la vez y la fórmula para
esto me diría que esto es 36 factorial
entre 36 menos nueve factorial
y también dividido entre 9 factorial lo
que está en verde es verde y lo que está
en naranja es naranja así que bien tengo
este número t de aquí y ese es el número
total de manos posibles
bien pues pasemos ahora a contar el
número de eventos favorables o lo que
decía es el número de manos
de manos con todos con todos
los unos esos son mis eventos favorables
son los que satisfacen esta condición
todos los unos estén en una mano ahora
bien si considero esto que es lo que
tengo que hacer pues las primeras cuatro
cartas ya están fijas todas tienen que
ser uno así que las primeras cuatro
cartas o bueno cuatro de las cartas más
bien no puedo hacerles nada eso me deja
cinco lugares disponibles con los que si
tengo un poco de movilidad ahora bien si
considero que de esas 36 cartas
distintas cause 4 digamos que me tocaron
todos los unos entonces para estos cinco
lugares sólo puede elegir entre treinta
y dos cartas distintas
ya elegí ahora 5 entonces aquí solo
puede elegir entre 31 acá sólo entre 30
y acá en 29 y aquí en 28 pero de nuevo
para estas 5 cartas tengo que considerar
como las puede acomodar porque de otro
modo estaría contando el doble bueno más
que el doble de hecho estaría contando
muchísimo más que el doble ahorita vamos
a ver cuánto así que bien de cuántas
formas las puede acomodar pues
nuevamente
en uno de los lugares de la mano puedo
poner cualquiera de las cinco cartas de
este grupo en el siguiente lugar puedo
poner cuatro porque ya como de una en el
siguiente tres en el siguiente dos y en
el siguiente uno así que en realidad el
número de manos con todos unos es este
número de aquí
este número de aquí este número salió
del hecho de que como tengo que tener
todos los unos en mi mano y son cuatro
de ellos solo hay cinco cartas en mi
mano en las cuales hay cierto grado de
libertad y ahora que tengo estas dos
cosas las puedo dividir para encontrar
la probabilidad en realidad esa fue la
razón de que no redujera más estas
fracciones ok entonces voy a tomar mi
número de manos que satisfacen mi
condición de tener todos los unos voy a
tomar
lo voy a copiar y pegar aquí abajito
para tener espacio
no pego por aquí y ahora voy a dividir
entre el número total de manos posibles
ahora voy a dividir entre el número
total de manos posibles dividir entre
esta fracción equivale a multiplicar por
su recíproco así que voy a agarrar esto
a copiar de nuevo
crearlo aquí y ahora voy a copiar el
numerador y ponerlo como el denominador
quizás se ve un poco feo porque hay unas
rayas ahí que se interponen en mi camino
pero espero que esto sirva para nuestros
propósitos así que tengo que hacer esta
división y faltar un producto y producto
5 por 4 por 3 por 2 por 1
lo tengo aquí abajo y lo tengo acá
arriba así que los puedo cancelar
en este luego 32 por 71 por 30 por 29
por 28 está aquí de nuevo en el
denominador así que también canceló esto
con esto de aquí
de modo que toda la expresión se reduce
9 x 8 por 7 por 6 / 36 por 35 por 34 por
33 y realmente lo que falta por hacer es
reducir ahora esta fracción de que me lo
voy a copiar también más abajo
vamos a reducir esta fracción de aquí
bien
entonces reducir esto veamos 9 entre 36
pues puedo dividir todo entre 9 esto se
convierte en un 48 entre 4 esto se
convertiría en un 2 este 4 se va 35 es 7
por 5 entonces puedo cancelar este 7
este 35 se convierte en un 5 puedo
dividir el 6 y el 33 entre 36 se
convertirá en 12 y el 33 en un 11 2 este
2 o por cancelar aquí y convertir este
34 en un 17
y entonces todo se reduce a 2 entre 5
por 17 por 11
ok entonces 5 por 17 por 11 quizás
podría haber hecho esto a mano pero soy
un poco flojo así que en 935 así que
toda mi expresión se convirtió
simplemente en 2 en 3 935
esa es la probabilidad de sacar todos
los unos en una mano en otras palabras
la probabilidad de que eso suceda es
alrededor de una en 500 por eso es tan
complicado sacar un poker en un juego de
cartas